[Música]
hola si yo les preguntara a ustedes cuál
es su pasión espero que la mayoría
supiera que responderme pues si hace
nueve años habían dicho que estaría
parada aquí la verdad es que no me lo
hubiera creído
como les dije en la introducción yo soy
actriz tengo no soy conductora soy
escritora tengo nueve años viviendo al
internet y viviendo en internet sin
embargo y no vengo a hablarles de esas
cosas el día de hoy estoy aquí para
hablarles como una vagabunda mochilera
ya que es mi mayor talento y es que está
para ser un mago 1 mochilero necesito es
tener talento ya sea pedir raid
y vestirte descolorida mente voy
descolorida mente ligar con extranjeros
y es que desde el 2014 conocí una
gallega la cual me enseñó que la vida
hay cosas mucho más importantes que
cargar en tu mochila con una plancha 20
prendas que no serás del viaje o unos
tacones ella me enseñó mi independencia
como mujer me enseñó incluso poner una
casa de campaña me enseñó aquí yo tenía
el poder de mis decisiones también me
enseñas alto a ti española pero sorry
hoy no les traje tortilla española son
muchos aparte se me va a echar a perder
el camión sin embargo les traigo mi
mochila con todo lo necesario para que
ustedes se conviertan en un muy buen
chileno ya que mi primer interés en esta
plática es que ustedes al salir de aquí
los y los siguientes que piensen sea a
dónde me voy a ir en mi próximo viaje
y esque
todo en esta vida es peligroso y yo
cuando yo empecé sen mochilera mi papá
me dijo estás loca eso ya no se asesora
de los 80s te puede pasar algo pero el
peligro está en todos lados imagínense
que no saliera de tu casa por miedo a
convertirte en un meme o una ley de en
internet aprovecha tu vida ya que nadie
más la va a aprovechar por ti no tengas
miedo de ser libre cree tela date cuenta
de que puedes con todo y que tu único
limitante eres tú mismo tu miedo a ver
díganme que te falta para viajar dinero
yo conocí a un chico que se llama
roberto el viviendo aquí pero él estuvo
viviendo en londres ocho meses y él no
tiene dinero para viajar se acabó su
intercambio y se quedó y dijo yo me voy
a quedar aquí porque yo no quiero volver
no él en méxico vendía cosas en tepito
para pagar sus estudios
él se aferró tanto con quedarse en
europa tanto así que vivía en un arbusto
en este lustro él vivía estuvo viendo
durante ocho meses y agarraba internet
del wifi más cercano de un hotel me
contó que él para bañarse para
gimnasio y todas las mañanas se
levantaba se iba al gimnasio y saliendo
al gimnasio se bañaba y se va a trabajar
ganaba dinero sin embargo por ser
foráneo no le pagan lo suficiente sólo
pagar sus clases de inglés cuando estuvo
último viviendo en esta planta ocho
meses y después de ese tiempo juntó
dinero para pagarse la escuela y todo
eso después de eso se fue a tokio y
ahora vive con su esposa y su bebé el
niño del medio y su hermanito el roberto
me enseñó una cosa muy importante no que
te vaya a salir ocho meses a una planta
no por favor no lo hagan sin embargo me
enseñó algo muy importante que es que el
dinero no tiene que es una limitante si
no tiene sino para dejar pues hacer
muchas cosas no sé igual y fue si yo
canto bailo como yo que no puedes hacer
muchísimas cosas en mi caso pues yo no
canto ninguna de esas cosas sin embargo
soy actriz este turba no por lo cual
decidí cuando no tuve dinero en mi
segundo viaje mochilero fue de españa'
amsterdam no tenemos dinero sin embargo
pues yo dije mis amigos qué les parece
si me visto de zombi con tierra del
parque compramos pintura roja y en menos
de 20 minutos juntamos 19 euros hasta
que llegó la policía me dijo señorita
pues está asustando niños
es por eso que les digo que usen sus
talentos en cualquier mano puedes ver
artistas independientes lugares de todos
lados que te pueden decir oye no sabes
cómo se muestran en tus cosas el que es
perico donde quieras verme otra cosa que
me pasa mucho cuando le digo a la gente
de que es que qué hacemos chile de que
te arriesgas mail es saber que necesitas
y yo les digo pues mira lo primero que
te recomiendo que lleves es un gas
pimienta
y me dicen nada de su nacimiento súper
sencillo lo único que necesitas es agua
chile y cayena chile de cayón es lo
mismo pimienta lo cuela y me pusiera
para que no deje funcionar el aerosol y
ya esto nos aeropuerto nadie te va a
decir nada es súper seguro y si después
un amigo que te sirva en internet puedes
comprar este es rosita siempre
pero siempre dos cosas y me decir nombre
ya si me quieres motivar hace un
mochilero que quieras que me maten pp
ligas en todos lados o sea tú tienes que
salir y simplemente disfrutarlo porque
al final
si te vas a quedar toda tu vida
encerrado pensando de que te vas a
convertir una ley de un internet o un
meme pues no vas a poder soltar tu vida
aprovecha tu vida que estoy de nadie más
fíjense que cuando les contaba no lo
dejan de mí todo esto cuando yo estuve
viajando y mochilera aprendí hace una
persona más empática con las personas
también les tengo esta frase que hice
las cosas disfruté las cosas que
realmente valen la pena para explicarles
esta frase les traigo algo muy
indispensable para vivir realmente sin
esto nadie de ustedes puede viajar y es
agua van a decir por qué porque toda esa
agua negra pues justamente en varanasi
en el cangués es el río mundialmente
conocido como el río más contaminado del
mundo puedes ver en este río a gente
agarrando del barro de la orilla
lavándose los dientes puedes ver a gente
bañándose súper feliz gente que su sueño
es morir aquí porque es un servicio de
reencarnar
es gente que te proyecta mucho y luego
tú llegas a méjico y te quedas porque el
agua está fría no o la desperdicios
viajando a mochilero aprendí que debes
hacer más en particular las personas te
das cuenta el valor que tienes te das
cuenta de qué valor tiene es como
persona que cualquier esto único
limitante
para mostrar la siguiente cosa que
traigo porque tengo muchísimas cosas mi
maleta
pues les voy a contar una anécdota yo me
fui de mochilera oporto portugal fue mi
primer viaje muy china en ese que no
teníamos dinero para viajar y pues tú
tienes esta servidora
pues como no tenemos dinero y todo esto
y de nombre pues no vamos a salir ni de
españa sin embargo cuando nos vamos de
viaje
todo el mundo nos ofreció comida agua
duchas y muchísimas gracias dios os
bendiga porque nos ofrecieron huichas
porque la verdad si no hubiéramos
sobrevivido sin embargo me queda algo
muy muy muy claro sobre este viaje que
es que tú eres tu limitante si no tienes
dinero para viajar aquí te mal para
viajar dígame dónde se quieren ir a ver
a dónde te quieres ir de viaje a dónde
se quiere ir de viaje
japón china chile y japón así de fácil
como que tú buscas en google lugares
baratos para ir a japón 15 lugares que
tengo que visitar en japón que son super
baratos hoteles baratos conocer gratis y
que es perico dónde quieres ver de la
siguiente cosa que les voy a contar es
algo que es muy importante para mí y es
que simplemente te dejes de llevar
disfrute cada cosa que vivas sea dolor
de espalda estar cansado y el trabajo en
las mañanas dolor de espalda cualquier
cosa que vivas disfrútalo confía en ti y
verás que encontrarás el camino pero ojo
confiar en ti no quiere decir tener
suerte a mí todo mundo a lo largo de mi
vida me dicen nada me extraña con tiene
una cuenta tú tienes mucha suerte todo
lo que te pasa a ti es por suerte yo les
digo no no tengo suerte lo que pasa es
que me aviento hacer las cosas el
problema de la gente que no sale de su
zona de confort y no le pasan cosas
ultra mágicas es porque no las busca
quítense esa nube de negatividad que si
también en un lugar que si no sabes
dónde ir pero quiere decir vete y
encontrarás el camino conocerás
muchísima gente que te va ayudar en tu
camino y te vas a dar cuenta
puedes hacer lo que tú quieras
viajando me empecé a dar cuenta que la
vida es como un videojuego así porque
porque como un videojuego no se les ha
pasado de videojuegos que es un mapa
negro y tú lo vas destapando pues es eso
fue mi vida no para mí viajar me hizo
darme cuenta que pues es un mapa y que
simplemente tú vas es tapando los
lugares quítense seguido de viajar y
destape en su propio mapa del mundo les
juro que saber mucho más bonito más
colorido
[Aplausos]
el diseño mapa del mundo y aún me faltan
muchísimos lugares por conocer deja de
creer todo lo que vean las películas del
mundo a través de tus propios ojos
conoce enamórate de se enamora te regala
pero siempre recuerda que tú tienes el
control de tu vida y que tú puedes hacer
lo que tú quieras también en los viajes
también aprendí también en los viajes
aprendí que para llevármelo también en
mis viajes aprendí que realmente tú no
se me puedes llegar a decir que no sea
otra limitante dices el dinero tengo
dinero
ya les dije cómo pueden salir el
problema del dinero me sé no sé cómo no
se habla del idioma la verdad es que me
tomé entendido por señas y lo más
importante es de eso que tú no quieras
transmisión en el mundo tu pasión lo que
tú misión lo que a ti te gusta yo cuando
viajé descubrí que mi pasión y lo que
más me motiva en el mundo es estar
parado aquí y transmitiéndoles este amor
que yo tengo por llegar igualito me
puedes decir que el sueño tu vida es el
doctor ser madre y que vive eeuu hay 20
sueños
al contrario cada quien tiene su propia
mente la vida y si algo aprendido
mientras viajo es que tú tienes el poder
si eso ya se los digo muchas veces y
también que no importa cualquier cosa
clint para tu misión no importa lo que
tú hagas al final está bien es tu
destino y es lo que tú tienes que hacer
de mochila porque si yo descubrí que mi
pasión en los viajes y así como me
cambió la vida yo quiero que ustedes las
cambie para que vivan sus sueños porque
viajar destapa el mundo de descubrir
cómo es el mundo te vuelves una persona
empática y aparte de todo eso descubres
que tú mismo tú o sea tú tú puedes hacer
lo que quieras y que en los viajes ves
las cosas como son no es una película
no es algo que aprendes en la escuela o
en una conferencia
yo la verdad es que estoy muy feliz de
estar aquí con ustedes y espero que
después de este viaje después de que
después de esta plática lo primero que
hagas es salir corriendo y compres un
boleto de viaje porque te lo juro que te
no no te vas a arrepentir amplia esta
visión del mundo y te vuelves una
persona más simpática con todo el mundo
por favor ama toma tu mochila y vete
después me lo va a agradecer muchas
veces por escucharme
[Aplausos]